now you wrote a book a few years ago
called principles
that sold millions of copies usually
books the business world don't sell
millions of copies and millions of them
were sold in in china as well
um what is it
that was in that book that was so
exciting to people when i would make
decisions
i
would not just make the decisions i
would think about what are the criteria
that i would use to make the decisions
and i'd write them down those are the
principles and then in our culture which
is this idea of meritocracy we would say
are those criteria good or bad and then
we would try to put them into algorithms
and equations and so
i would do that almost like a diary kind
of thing and i would see the same things
happening over and over again and the
next time it happened i would go to the
principal and we could together go to
our principals and so it accumulated
that over a period of time and they were
practical they're not theoretical
principles and people seem to find them
valuable